I'm going to go ahead now and get
started with some sixth century material,
which really a prophetic literature which
confronts the issues that were raised
by the destruction that's the
final destruction of Jerusalem.
What was the meaning of this event and
how could it be reconciled with the
concept of Israel as God's elect?
How could such tremendous evil and
suffering be reconciled with the nature of
God himself?
This is going to be a a question that
will return in the next lecture on when we
look at the wisdom literature and the
book of job and some other texts as well
as we proceed through the rest of
the course. In classical terms,
if God is God,
then he's not good.
If all these terrible things
happened and if God is good,
then he mustn't be all powerful
because he failed to prevent this evil.
So that tends to be the dilemma.
The way it's phrased now,
a Zico was a priest and he was
deported in the first deportation.
You already remember there was a
deportation of exiles and five 97.
And then the final siege
and destruction and exile,
deportation of exiles and five 87 is
Nico was among the deportees of five 97.
He was therefore in exile in Babylon
during the final destruction and the fall
of Jerusalem in five 87.
But his priestly background
in his priestly interests
are clearly reflected in
his prophecies.
He accuses the Israelites of
failing to observe cultic laws,
ritual laws, uh, and his promises for the
future. In his vision of a restoration,
we'll see center around a new temple
and a restored a Jerusalem and temple
complex. There's a striking
correspondence between his ego and,
um, and the priestly sources
in terms of language and theme,
particularly h the holiness code.
Now,
the prophecies in Ezekiel conveniently
and unlike many of the other prophetic
books actually follow a
fairly chronological order.
So the First Section of the book consists
of prophecies that were before the
final destruction between five 97,
five 87. And then beginning in 33.
It seems that we have
prophecies that followed the
destruction. We here, you know,
he, he gets the report of the destruction
and then we see how his tone and his
message changes.
So in those first 24 chapters where you
have prophecies that are delivered in
Babylon before the destruction,
we have three chapters that are
devoted to his call and his commission.
As a prophet,
we see his inaugural vision.
I'll come back and talk about that in a
minute as well as many other visions and
symbols.
Then you have from chapters four to 24
oracles that are condemning Judah and
Israel. There's some interesting
elements within this. We have, um,
the depiction of the coveted, which
represents God. I'm departing,
we'll talk about that text in a minute.
We also have in chapter 18,
a very interesting,
uh,
emphasis on individual responsibility
for sin will come back and touch on that
as well.
Chapters 25 to 32 contain Oracle's
against foreign nations just as we have in
Jeremiah and Isaiah. Um, throughout, uh,
is eco refers to these
nations as the uncircumcised.
The tone here is vengeful and,
and very gloating.
And these oracles have exerted a very
strong influence. On the New Testament,
particularly the book of revelation
after five 87 um,
Ezekiel prophesied and those prophecies
are contained in the latter part of his
book from chapter 33 to 48.
So in 33 we hear of the fall of
Jerusalem and then after that Oracle's of
promise and hope for the future.
The last chapters from chapter 40 to
48 our visions is equals visions of the
restoration, his vision of a rebuilt
temple and to rebuilt Jerusalem.
So the book opens with a narrative account
of a z keels call and about five 93
or so in a Jewish community
that's on the river Tebar,
which is a large irrigation canal
off of the Euphrates in Babylon.
And this is the first time that we hear
of a call of a profit outside the land
of Israel.
It's a remarkable vision,
like many of the visions and the book of
Ezekiel, it has a sort of see realistic,
almost hallucinatory quality.
The vision itself is very reminiscent
of descriptions of by all the Canaanites
Storm God. So there's a stormy wind
and a huge cloud and a flashing fire.
God is writing on a kind of throne,
chariot.
He's enthroned above four
magnificent creatures.
Each of these has a human body and then
four faces the face of a human in the
face of Elian, the face of an
ox and the face of an eagle.
There are four huge wheels
under this throne chariot.
And they are said to gleam like barrel
beneath a vast and awe inspiring expanse
or dome which gleams like crystal.
Above that is the semblance of
a throne that is like Sapphire.
And on the throne was the semblance of a
human form or a gleaming like amber and
its fire in cased in a,
um,
a frame which is radiant all about.
So this Cavo,
this cloud that contains or hides
the fire that is Yahweh's presence.
That is also the term that's used in
the Torah in exodus and the priestly
sources to describe the presence
of God among his people.
This fire that's encased in a cloud,
the cuff vote in exodus 24,
we read that this coveted had settled on
Mount Sinai representing God's presence
in exodus 40.
This cloud covers the tent of meeting.
It fills the tabernacle.
So many [inaudible] sees it now.
He says that it was the appearance of the
semblance of the presence of the Lord.
When I be held it,
I flung myself down on my face and I
heard the voice of someone speaking.
Notice this language.
It was the assemblance of the appearance
of the presence is CQO wants to
emphasize the transcendent
nature of the deity. Uh,
he's having a vision of something which
cannot in fact be seen or perceived, uh,
which is a kind of paradox of
all of his visions. The profits,
humanity is emphasized in contrast
to this transcendent divinity, right?
And that's something that
happens throughout his ego.
He emphasizes his
humanity with this phrase,
son of man been a dumb son of man.
It's simply as the Hebrew term for a
mortal being as opposed to a divine being.
Son of man's simply means a
human, a mortal Benedum dumb
one who was like a dumb.
Now the call of his Cqo is reminiscent
of the call of Jeremiah and Isaiah.
He is sent to a nation of rebels,
rebels who will not be listening to him.
And his commission is symbolized by
a scroll that's handed to him. Um,
and we hear on the end,
at the end of chapter two that inscribed
on this scroll are limitations and
Durgin is and woes and he's commanded to
eat of this scroll and then go to speak
to the house of Israel.
So he swallows his scroll and
all of it's dreadful contents.
It tastes to him as sweet as honey.
And then his task is spelled
out in chapter three.
He is to be a watchmen one who gives
warning of danger and people will either
hate him or not,
but each one of them is ultimately
responsible for his or her own fate in a
vision in chapter eight
and Angel transports is EQL
to Jerusalem and into the
temple courts.
And there he sees and gives a very
vivid description of the shocking
abominations.
Um,
these are represented as justifying or
explaining the destruction of the city
and these, um, this do,
these descriptions are characterized by
more than the usual amount of prophetic
hyperbole as he watches the slaughter
and the destruction that's going on there
is Zeke sees the cover vode that is
the presence of Yat way arise from the
temple and move to the east chapter 10.
Then verses 18 and 19,
the presence of the Lord left the platform
of the house and stopped above the
cherubs.
And I saw the cherubs lift their wings
and rise from the earth with the wheels
beside them as they departed.
And they stopped at the entrance of the
eastern gate of the House of the Lord
with the presence of the god of Israel
above them. And then Chapter 11,
verses 23 to 25 then the presence of
the Lord ascended from the midst of the
city and stood on the
hill east of the city.
A spirit carried me away and brought me
in a vision by the spirit of God to the
exile community in cal Dhea.
So now he's back to Babylon.
And then the vision that I had seen left
me and I told the exiles all the things
that the Lord had shown me.
So this image draws on ancient
near eastern traditions
of God's abandoning their,
their cities and anger, leaving
them to destruction by another God.
The primary difference here is that God
rather than another God is himself also
bringing the destruction.
Moreover,
God doesn't retire to the heavens.
He doesn't abandon his people.
He doesn't remain behind
with those left in Judah,
but he moves into exile in the book of
Ezekiel. Those left behind are guilty.
God does stay with them.
God moves east with the righteous exiles.
Then at the end of the book of Ezekiel,
um,
we're going to see a vision
of a restored temple.
This happens in Ezekiel 43
and here is [inaudible].
We'll see the coveted returning from
the east and back to the temple and they
are coming from the east with a roar
like the roar of mighty waters was the
presence of the god of Israel.
And the earth was lit up by his presence.
The presence of the Lord entered the
temple by the gate that faced eastward and
low. The presence of the Lord filled the
temple. It was 43 verses one through six.
So just as the presence of divine
presence went eastward with the exile,
so the exiles,
so it will return with the
reestablishment of Israel in her home.
What is significant here is the idea
that God is not linked to a particular
place,
but to a particular people.
And the implication then is that God is
with his people even when they are in
exile.
So Ezekiel preached a message of
doom and judgment like his prophetic
predecessors and his contemporaries,
but his condemnations tend to emphasize
the people's idolatry and their moral
impurity. And this of course, makes
sense of his priestly heritage.
His denunciations of Jerusalem are among
the most lurid and violent that you'll
find in the Bible.
Again,
these prophecies were likely delivered
between the two deportations,
between five 97 and then the
final destruction and deportation,
and five 87 five 86 and his ego
warns that Jerusalem will fall,
deservedly. He says that rebellion against
Babylon would be treason against God.
He employs all kinds of very vivid
metaphors to describe Israel situation.
Jerusalem, he says is [inaudible]
sister, except even more vile.
Jerusalem is a vine,
but a wild one or I burned one.
She produces nothing of
use. Purity language, uh,
is employed metaphorically
throughout Ezekiel.
Jerusalem has been utterly defiled
and there are all sorts of images that
inspire revulsion in these chapters.
So destruction is the
only possible remedy.
There are metaphors of sexual
promiscuity throughout the book.
Gods destruction of Israel is figured
as the abuse doled out by an insanely
jealous husband who is violent. And the
images are disturbing. They're haunting,
they're quite nightmarish. Ezekiel
also engages in various, um,
dramatic, um, signs, prophetic signs
or actions to convey his message.
It's something that we've seen
in some of the other profits,
but his are so bizarre and
so extreme sometimes, uh,
that he was accused of insanity.
He cooks his food over a fire of human
excrement as a symbol of the fact that
those besieged by Nobel book nets,
Netzer will be forced to eat unclean food.
He doesn't.
More.
And when his wife dies in order
to illustrate the fact that yeah,
we will not mourn the loss of his temple,
he binds himself in ropes.
He lies on his left side,
390 days to symbolize the hundred
90 years of exile of Israel.
And then he lies on his right side for
40 days to symbolize the length of Judas
captivity,
which he says will be 40 years.
Neither of these terms of
captivity turn out to be correct,
but finally he shaves his beard and
his hair and he burns a third of it.
He strikes a third of it with his sword
and he scatters a third of it to the
winds. He just keeps a few
hairs bound up in his robe.
And this is to symbolize the destruction
of a third of the people by pestilence
and famine,
a third of the people by violence
and the exile of a third to Babylon.
A only a few will God allow to escape.
And CQO makes it clear that those
who ignore the warnings are doomed.
Those who he'd will be spared.
And in this,
he sounds the theme of
individual responsibility
that is so characteristic of
Ezekiel.
Want you to listen to the following
passage and compare it to our think about
other verses or terms in the Torah that
you've studied that may relate to the
same topic. How is he, uh,
modifying those earlier ideas?
This is all from chapter 18,
various versus throughout.
The word of the Lord came to me.
What do you mean by quoting this
proverb upon the soil of Israel,
the parents eat sour grapes and their
children's teeth are blunted as I live,
declares the Lord God.
This proverb shall no longer
be current among you in Israel.
Consider all lives are mine.
The life of the parent and the
life of the child are both mine.
The person who sins only he shall die.
A child shall not share the
burden of a parent's guilt,
nor shall a parent share the
burden of a child's guilt.
The righteousness of the righteous
shall be accounted to him alone,
and the wickedness of the wicked shall
be accounted to him alone. Moreover,
if the wicked one repents of all the
sins that he committed and keeps all my
laws and does what is Justin Wright,
he shall live. I shall not die.
Is it my desire that a wicked
person shall die, says the Lord God?
It is rather that he shall turn back from
his ways and live so to if a righteous
person turns away from his righteousness
and does wrong practicing the very
abominations that the wicked
person practice shall he live.
None of the righteous deeds that he
did shall be remembered because of his
treachery he has practiced and the
sins he has committed because of these,
he shall die.
Be assured o house of Israel.
I will judge each one of you according
to his ways, declares the Lord God.
Repent and turn back from
all your transgressions.
Let them not be a stumbling
block of guilt for you.
Cast away all the transgressions by which
you have offended and get yourselves a
new heart and a new spirit
that you may not die.
O House of Israel for it is not
my desire that anyone shall die,
declares the Lord God.
Repent. Therefore and live,
it's an important Torah idea that is
EQL is rejecting or contradicting here.
And that's the Torah principle of
collective or even intergenerational
punishment. It's found most
famously in the second commandment,
the declaration that God
punish his children for the
sins of their fathers under
the fourth generation.
Now we need to note that we're talking
about divine justice here and not human
justice.
As we saw in our study of Biblical law
in the sphere of human justice only the
guilty or punished in Israelite
law, um, you don't have, um, uh,
you know, literal punishment.
Someone kills someone's son,
then their son is put to death.
That idea is rejected in biblical law,
but God operates according
to a different principal,
a principal of collective responsibility.
And that principle is understood in
the early sources quite positively,
that the sins of the fathers are visited,
visited upon the children is
an expression of God's mercy.
Exodus 34 verses six and seven
describes God as merciful and Gracious,
slow to anger and abounding in steadfast
love and faithfulness and that and thus
tolerating sin, though not completely
clearing the guilty as a mercy.
He spreads out the punishment over
three or four generations. Right?
So this notion is tied up with
the aspect of God's mercy.
But evidently there are
some who found this idea,
unjust and other biblical passages try
to bring a different sense of justice to
this picture.
And they emphasize that the third and
fourth generations themselves must be
wicked. Um, that seems to be the
case in exodus 20 verse five,
the Book of chronicles, which is a
rewrite of the historical material,
the historical narrative
in the book of Kings,
rewrites that material in a manner that
never explains a catastrophe on the
basis of guilt incurred by someone
other than the one experiencing the
catastrophe.
In other words,
it rejects the Deuteronomistic
historians device of delayed punishment,
which you already remember,
we discussed.
It changes the narrative account so that
no one suffers for a crime committed by
someone else.
It isn't the sin of an earlier generation
that's finally visited upon, you know,
a grandson or a king
of a later generation.
So it seems that after five 86 or
certainly in [inaudible] case, uh,
some accepted the idea that the nation
was suffering because of the accumulated
guilt of previous generations,
notably the deuteronomist,
but for others like is [inaudible]
the idea of accumulated guilt and
intergenerational punishment seemed
to lose some of its explanatory power
perhaps because the,
the destruction and the exile seem to
devastating least severe punishments that
didn't fit the individual crimes.
So as [inaudible] is one who rejects the
doctrine of collective responsibility
in the operation of divine
justice in chapter 18,
he responds to the idea of suffering
for the sins of one's ancestors by
declaring that God isn't going
to work that way anymore,
God will no longer punish people.
Collectively,
each one will be judged individually
only this center will be punished and
that's a major departure from exodus
34 and even from the contemporaneous
Deuteronomistic view.
And at this point I think we would do
well to remind ourselves of the nature of
the biblical text.
And they,
in the opening lecture I asked you to
set aside certain presuppositions about
the biblical text.
One of them is that it is a uniform or
unified text with a single doctrine or
theology. I asked you to remember that
the Bible isn't a book, it's a library.
It's a library of works that originate
in vastly different historical periods,
vastly different historical situations
and responds to a variety of shifting
needs and events and reflects a range of
perceptions about God and his relation
to creation and to Israel.
It isn't a book of theology that is to
say rational argumentation in supportive
certain doctrines about God.
And it most certainly doesn't speak with
a single voice on points of theology or
matters that are of traditional
concern to the discipline of theology.
Doctrine isn't it's concern,
understanding and making sense of
the historical odyssey of the nation,
of Israel in covenant with God.
That is its concern.
And so we're going to find many different
interpretations of the meaning of that
history and the nature of that God
and the meaning of that covenant.
And certainly there are some
basic points of agreement,
but even some of the most basic points
of agreement do not pass without some
contest station. So, for example,
the basic point that humans
are free moral agents.
This seems to be clearly
assumed throughout most of
the books of this little
library,
but there are some isolated episodes
that would appear to contradict even that
most basic assumption. God Hardens
Pharaoh's heart, God's seals,
the people's ears sometimes so that
they will not hear the message of the
profits or will not understand
them until a later day.
To be sure there are only a few
of these contradictory passages,
but they do exist.
And so here we find also a major shift
in the exotic period away from the
tendency to see divine justice working
through collective or intergenerational
punishment to the idea of the individual,
the individual's culpability before God.
I shouldn't say a shift away.
We see a rising a dialectic, right?
This isn't a linear progression.
These are different ideas coming out at
different times and receiving emphasis
at different times.
But this kind of polyphony then didn't
impinge upon the authority of the Hebrew
Bible for the nation of Israel because
the Bible's authority doesn't arrive from
some suppose it consistency or universal
quality. That's a modern notion.
And it's based on Hellenistic ideals
of truth as singular western culture
influenced by Greek philosophical
traditions defines truth,
truth in monistic terms only that which
contains no contradiction is true.
And only that which is
true is authoritative.
Those notions are somewhat alien to
the ancient non hellenized world.
The Bible doesn't strive to
present philosophical truth.
It presents the best efforts of sages and
profits and scribes and visionaries to
respond to and to explain the crises of
the nation over a period of centuries.
And it's authority derives from the
explanatory power of its insights into and
understanding of God's governance of
the world and his plans for Israel.
So those insights and those
understandings may shift and even stand in
contradiction with one another,
but they're not mutually exclusive and
they're contradictions don't affect their
authority,
their ability to explain,
to console their ability to
nourish the faith of a people,
convinced that God
would never desert them,
no matter how difficult it may be to
understand his interactions with them
back to a Zico. Now. And in chapter 33,
we learned that a fugitive from Jerusalem
brings news of the fall of Jerusalem.
So it's a about five 80,
75,
86 and when he hears this
is the Keel exchanges,
his message of doom for a message
of hope before the fall of the city,
his task had been to shatter
the people's illusions.
You wanted to shake them
out of their complacency,
but now reduced to
despair. Um, and remorse.
The people are reduced
to despair and remorse.
And his task is to offer reassurance
and hope God is going to initiate a new
beginning.
Though Israel's punishment was deserved.
It was not according
to his own [inaudible],
a sign of the end of the relationship
between you halfway and his people.
And a new Israel would rise from
the remnant of Judah and Israel.
And he expresses this restoration by
means of many metaphors and visions.
So chapter 34 condemns the shepherds.
This is a very common ancient near
eastern metaphor for the leadership of the
people at King is always
a shepherd and so on.
So chapter 34 condemns the shepherds
of the people and promise this,
this promises to set up in the future,
one shepherd of the house of David
to be prince among the people.
Chapter 36 uses metaphors
of purity and cleansing.
Israel will be cleansed from
the impurities of the past.
She'll be given a new
covenant of the heart.
This is verses 24 and 25 and chapter 36
I will take you from among the nations
and gather you from all the countries and
I will bring you back to your own land
and I will sprinkle clean water upon you,
right pure water upon you
and you shall be clean, pure.
I will cleanse you from all
your uncleanness and from
all your fetishes and I
will give you a new heart and
put a new spirit into you.
I will remove the heart of stone from
your body and give you a heart of flesh
and I will put my spirit into you.
Thus I will cause you to follow my laws
and faithfully to observe my rules.
Those echoes here of Jeremiah also.
And then you shall dwell in the land
which I gave to your fathers and you shall
be my people and I will be your God.
So we have again,
this almost utopian, a redesign of
human nature that we heard in Jeremiah.
One in which the problems that are
associated with the exercise of free will
maybe obviated.
Another metaphor that's used for the
restoration of a new Israel out of the
remnant of the old, um, is the
metaphor of revival from death.
And this is found in chapter 37 very,
very famous passage is equals
vision of the valley of dry bones.
The hand of the Lord came upon me.
He took me out by the spirit of the Lord
and set me down in the valley and it
was full of bones.
He led me all around them.
There were very many of them spread
over the valley and they were very dry.
And he said to me, Oh, mortal, can these
bones live again? Have you applied?
Oh Lord God only, you know, very
diplomatic answer. And he said to me,
prophesy over these bones and
say to them, oh, dry bones.
Hear the word of the Lord and thus said,
the Lord God to these bones,
I will cause breath to enter
you and you shall live again.
I will lay sinews upon you and cover you
with flesh and formed skin over you and
I will put breath into you and you shall
live again and you shall know that I am
the Lord. I prophesied as I had been
commanded. And while I was prophesying,
suddenly there was a sound of
rattling and the bones came together,
bone to matching bone.
I looked and there were sinews on them
and flesh had grown and skin and formed
over them.
The breath entered them and they came
to life and stood up on their feet,
a vast multitude. And he
said to me, oh, mortal,
these bones are the whole house of
Israel. They say, our bones are dried up,
our house is gone. We are doomed.
Prophesied therefore, and say to them,
thus said the Lord God,
I am going to open your graves and lift
you out of the graves of my people and
bring you to the land of Israel. You
shall know my people, that I am the Lord.
When I have opened your graves
and lifted you out of your graves,
I will put my breath into you and you
shall live again and I will set you upon
your own soil. Then you shall know that
I, the Lord have spoken and have acted,
declares the Lord. So in the
interpretation that follows the vision,
we're told that the bones symbolize
Israel. Now in this state, in exile,
in their despair, they're crying,
our bones are dried up, were dead,
our hope is lost and God promises
to raise Israel from the grave,
which is the metaphor for exile and
restore her to her own land as one people
north and south with one
prince to rule over her.
This text is often been
decontextualized and cited as a,
as a old testament or Hebrew Bible
source for the doctrine of literal
resurrection after death as if it's
speaking about literal resurrection.
But I think in its context it's,
it's quite clear that it is one of many
metaphors that is equal uses throughout
this section for the redemption of
the egg of the community from exile,
the restoration of the people back in
their own land at the center of the
restored community that is Eko.
Envisions is a new Jerusalem at at its
center is a rebuilt temple and it's
described in great detail in the last
nine chapters of the book is he kills
Utopian Vision.
The land is equally allotted.
It's divided up in equally a lot of among
all 12 tribes now who will be brought
back and Jerusalem lies in the
center with 12 get great gates,
one for each tribe surrounding
it. Um, it's the, uh,
this temple is the source of a never
ending river that gushes forth from it.
A river that will make the Dead Sea flow
with freshwater again, uh, is the Keel,
sees Satta kite priests
presiding in the temple.
They are assisted by [inaudible] who
are just meals or sort of demoted in his
vision and he insists no
foreigners will be permitted entry.
And we're going to see that that's a
view that wasn't shared by others in the
post destruction era.
While [inaudible] believed that God would
restore a purified Israel to its land
under a Davidic monarchy and
he prophesied to this effect,
he like Jeremiah also maintained that
our relationship with God was possible.
In the meantime,
a relationship outside the chosen
land and the Jewish diaspora,
right diaspora refers to a community
living outside of its home land.
The Jewish diaspora was a new thing.
It was a religious,
national body of a type that
had not been seen before.
You had a people remaining loyal to their
god while in exile from their own land
and what was believed to be that God's
land without worshiping him cultic Lee or
by means of sacrifice.
Remember,
the only legitimate site for an alter
or for sacrifice to God is Jerusalem and
in time slowly a new worship will
be fashioned one without sacrifice.
One that consists of prayer and confession
and fasts and other kinds of ritual
observances.
Three times a day Jews will
pray and they'll pray in
the direction of Jerusalem.
Worship in synagogues
eventually will come into being.
And the importance of the Sabbath will
grow the sabbath as a memorial of the
covenant and a symbol of Jewish faith.
And so you also find beginning shortly
after this period for the first time,
non Jews are joining themselves too.
Yeah,
way adopting this religion of
Israel out of religious conviction.
Not simply because they may be residing
in the land and have to follow the God's
laws.
This is outside the land.
You have people choosing to opt
into this community. So again,
we see that as the history of the
nation of Israel came to an end,
the history of Judaism and religion,
Judaism begins.
So in a Cqo we've seen um,
one response to the national
disaster and the exile.
The idea that while suffering and
punishment are fully deserved,
a relationship with God remains possible.
God is with his people. Even in exile.
A second response to the destruction
and exile can be found in the anonymous
writings that are appended to the book
of Isaiah mentioned these writings
briefly. We'll be able to look now at
what's been called second. Does Isaiah.
So there are two discrete units of
material that are appended to Isaiah.
Chapters 40 to 55 or referred
to a second Isaiah. And, uh,
chapters 56 to 66 are referred to us.
Third Isaiah.
And these chapters differ from Isaiah
proper in the eighth century prophet. Uh,
in several ways, it's clear
first of all that, um,
these parts of Isaiah were
written after the, um,
after the exile to a large
parts of Isaiah. Third,
Isaiah were written after the exile.
All of Second Isaiah
and Isaiah proper was clearly
written in the eighth century on,
into the early seventh century. Um,
Jerusalem is referred to as destroyed.
The audience that's addressed is living
in exile. Babylon is the oppressor,
not Assyria. Assyria was the oppressor
and the time of Isaiah proper.
So the upended materials,
uh,
even seem to know of the
overthrow of the Babylonians.
That's going to happen in about five 39
when Cyrus of Persia will destroy a will,
will conquer the Babylonians.
Um,
we have passages that express
some euphoria over this. Um,
because Cyrus of course authorized the
Jews to return from Babylon to Jerusalem
to rebuild the temple.
There are also all kinds of
stylistic differences between first,
Isaiah and second and third Isaiah. Um,
second and third. Isaiah for example,
I have no biographical data and
first Isaiah has quite a bit,
these materials also have a
different theology of history,
different understanding of history at
different attitude towards foreign nations
and a very strong and renewed
emphasis on monotheism.
And these also market as
different, um, in the,
among the scrolls that were found in the
caves of Qumran near the Dead Sea. Uh,
we have a very large and
very famous Isaiah Scroll,
which is now in a museum in Jerusalem.
And on the scroll there's a gap after
Isaiah 39 and a new column starts with
Isaiah 40. So it seems to signal some sort
of implicit recognition that there's a
difference between these two sections.
They are not the same.
They're not the same units,
not the same author perhaps.
So we're going to talk right now about
second Isaiah because this is a holy post
destruction work. The opening or
inaugural oracle that happens in,
in that occurs in chapter 40
is an oracle of constellation.
It's an oracle of comfort and the
profits sees a straight and level highway
prepared in the wilderness for a
dramatic procession of Yak way.
The shepherd who will lead his people
back to Jerusalem, very, very famous,
made very famous by
Handel's Messiah actually.
So chapter 40 taking from various
verses in this chapter, Comfort, Oh,
comfort my people,
says your God,
speak tenderly to Jerusalem and declare
to her that her term of services over
that her iniquity is expiated for she
has received at the hand of the Lord
double for all her sins of voice
rings out clear in the desert,
a road for the Lord level in the
wilderness, a highway for our God.
Let every valley be raised.
Every hill and mount made low.
Let the rugged ground become level
and the ridges become a plane.
The presence of the Lord shall appear
and all flesh as one shall behold,
for the Lord himself has spoken. A
voice rings out, proclaim another asks,
what shall I proclaim?
All flesh is grass,
all its goodness like
flowers of the field.
But the word of our God is always
fulfilled. Behold the Lord God comes in,
might like a shepherd.
He pastors his flock,
he gathers the lambs in his arms and
carries them in his bosom gently.
He drives the mother sheep.
So this highway will appear leading
the exiles straight to Jerusalem.
All of the topography will be flattened
and God will lead them as a shepherd
leads the lamb. Why? Because the
word of the Lord is always fulfilled.
So what this voice is proclaiming
is a literal return from exile.
God's opening a highway.
He's leading his flock home
like a shepherd in a new exodus.
And this is an idea that's so important
that it recurs at the end of the unit as
well.
In chapter 55 the idea of a new exodus,
a second key theme that sounded at the
beginning and end of the unit again.
So it happens in chapter 40 and again
in chapter 55 is this idea that the word
of our God is always fulfilled
or in some translations,
the word of our God stands forever.
This idea is the essence of the Israelites
hope during the period of captivity
and exile and it appears
in the first oracle.
It's beautifully restated in the last
Oracle and chapter 55 verses 10 through 12
for as the rain or snow drops from heaven
and returns not there but soaks the
earth and makes it bring forth vegetation,
yielding seed for sowing
and bred for eating.
So is the word that issues from my mouth,
it doesn't come back to me unfulfilled
but performs what I propose achieves what
I sent it to do.
The AAU shall leave and joy and be led
home secure before you mount and Hill
shall shout aloud and all the trees
of the field shall clap their hands.
So the everlasting word of the Lord,
it's guaranteed fulfillment specifically
to bring his people home in a new
exodus. These are ideas, they
form an envelope or an inclusio,
that kind of literary structure where
something has mentioned at the beginning
and again at the end to form an inclusio
or an envelope around the entire unit
of Second Isaiah.
We see awesome in second
Isaiah and extreme monotheism.
The monotheism is explicit of course
in Isaiah, implicit, I'm sorry,
implicit in Isaiah, but it becomes
quite explicit. And Second Isaiah, um,
as we've seen,
uh,
to come to terms with the destruction
of five 87 entails the acceptance of the
idea that Israel is punishment was
deserved and that, yeah, he controls,
um, and you always control of history
means he controls not only Israel,
but all other nations as well
and can use them for his purpose,
including punishing Israel.
There's no power other than Yaffe way.
So referring then to the
rise and fall of nations, um,
Isaiah 41 verse four states who
has wrought and achieved this,
he who announced the
generations from the start.
I The Lord who was first and
we'll be with the last as well.
The first and the last, which is a way of
saying everything right, all inclusive.
There is nothing but me and Isaiah 44
satirizes those nations who make and
worship idols and ridicules the folly
and stupidity of ascribing divinity to
that which one has created
with one's own hands.
And Isaiah 41 God's states,
his case against these
vane and useless idols.
He summons them to answer for themselves,
show that they are gods by
announcing something that will occur,
announcing what will occur
and seeing if it comes true.
Chapter 41 2124 let them approach
and tell us what will happen.
Tell us what has occurred and we will
take note of it or announced to us what
will occur and we may know the outcome
foretell what is yet to happen that we
may know that you are gods.
Do anything good or bad that we need
maybe odd and see why you are less than
nothing.
Your effect is less than t one
who chooses you is an abomination.
But this is only half the picture because
not only are the gods of the nations,
no gods, but yeah, white is the true
God of all of these other nations.
So who raised Cyrus of Persia from the
north to sweep through the ancient near
east and conquer the Babylonians?
No one but yeah way.
Isaiah 41 I have roused him from the
north and he has come and he has trampled
rulers like mud,
like a potter treading clay.
The things once predicted to Zion behold,
here they are.
So in these passages,
the author of second Isaiah is drawing
a the logical conclusion perhaps towards
which Israelite religion has tended
from its inception Yaffe way once the
Canaanites Deity,
then the God of Israel's Patriarchs,
then the national God of Israel is here,
the Lord of universal history,
the only real God, second Isaiah
is claiming is the god of Israel.
Second Isaiah is also a quite well known
for the servant songs that it contains
the famous servant songs.
These occur, I'm scattered.
And in chapter 42 chapter 49 chapter 50
and then most extensively 52 13 to 53 12
so much of 52 and 53 the
identity of this sermon,
I'll read some of these passages in a
minute, but it refers to this servant God,
God's servant,
and the identity of the servant has been
a puzzle to biblical interpreters for
centuries. Sometimes the servant is
referred to as a collective figure.
Sometimes servant is referred
to as an individual figure.
And Chapter 49 the servant is referred
to or described as a prophet with a
universal message rather than a
message for the Israelites alone.
But then there's some ambiguity here.
The Servant is first
identified or the profit,
the servant or profit is first
identified as Israel, herself.
So in chapter 49 verses one to three
the Lord appointed me before I was born.
He named me while I was
in my mother's womb.
He made my mouth like a sharpened blade.
He hit me in the shadow of his hand
and he made me like a polished arrow.
He concealed me in his
quiver and he said to me,
you are my servant Israel in whom I glory,
and yet in verse five it would seem that
this profit servant has a mission to
Israel to bring her back to Yahweh and
that would imply that the servant or
profit is not Israel.
Verse Five and now the Lord has resolved
he who formed me in the womb to be his
servant, to bring back Jacob to himself,
that Israel may be restored to him.
Right then the mission has expanded a
little bit in verse six for he has said it
is too little that you
should be my servant.
In that I raise up the tribes of Jacob
and restore the survivors of Israel.
I will also make you a light unto the
nations that my salvation may reach the
ends of the earth.
Chapter 50 quite famously refers to the
servant as rebellious and as persecuted.
Verse six I offered my
back to the floggers and my
cheeks to those who tore out
my hair. I did not hide my
face from insult and spittle,
but it's the famous and difficult
passage in Isaiah 53 that most movingly
describes the suffering and
sorrow of God's servant.
53 verses three to 11 he was despised.
We held him,
have no account,
yet it was our sickness that he was
bearing our suffering that he endured.
We accounted him, played,
smitten and afflicted by God,
but he was wounded because of our sins
crushed because of our iniquities.
He bore the chastisement that made us
whole and by his bruises we are healed.
We all went astray like sheep,
each going his own way,
and the Lord visited upon him the
guilt of all of us. He was maltreated,
yet he was submissive.
He did not open his mouth like a sheep
being led to slaughter like a you dumb
before those who she or her,
he did not open his mouth and his grave
was said among the wicked and with the
rich.
In his death,
though he had done no injustice
and had spoken no false hood,
but the Lord chose to
crush him by disease.
That if he made himself
an offering for guilt,
he might see offspring and have long
life and that through him the Lord's
purpose might prosper.
There've been many attempts to equate
this man of sorrows with all kinds of
figures.
Early on,
Jesus's followers saw Jesus as a
suffering servant of God. In Isaiah,
the new testament writers specifically
borrowed passages from Isaiah,
particularly this chapter,
chapter 33 when constructing
their narratives of Jesus,
taking those verses and using
them in describing his story.
So he is depicted as the innocent and
righteous servant who suffered for the
sins of others. In the
teachings of Paul. However,
you have a different use of these versus
Christians generally are identified as
a servant who suffers with and for Jesus.
Despite these later
theological interpretations,
the anonymous writer of Second Isaiah
wasn't writing about a remote and as Urbi
and teacher and charismatic healer who
would live more than five centuries later
examined in its original context,
it appears most likely
that the servant is Israel.
Herself described metaphorically as an
individual who's present suffering and
humiliation is due to the
sins of other nations,
but whose future restoration
and exaltation will cause
astonishment among those
nations who will then
be humbled to halfway.
But there are problems with even this
interpretation and you should be aware of
that this has never been
solved satisfactorily.
The main problem with interpreting
Israel as the servant, uh,
is the verse that describes the
servant as having a mission to Israel.
It seems a little odd to say that
Israel Bayer is a mission to Israel,
but this problem can be solved if we
remember that Israel was often divided and
prophetic rhetoric. So perhaps the
writer envisions emission of one part,
the right shit, the righteous part to
the other, the part that has gone astray.
Leaving aside this difficulty,
the more prominent Motif in the servant
Song of Isaiah is that the servant has a
mission to the world.
That's the more prominent motif and that
is a role that would suit Israel quite
well for the, furthermore,
you have the phrase Israel,
my servant appearing in Second
Isaiah about eight times.
So the idea of Israel as God's servant
to the nations is clearly a part of
Isaiah's conceptual world.
And since we're dealing with poetry
rather than a rigorously consistent
metaphysical treatise,
uh,
it shouldn't be too surprising
that sometimes a servant
is spoken of as a group
collectively,
sometimes as an individual.
The same holds true of Israel in general,
by the way,
throughout much of the literature,
sometimes Israel is spoken of in
plural terms and sometimes as a single
individual.
So in its original context,
it's likely that the servant
refers to Israel herself.
If the servant is Israel,
then we can see how second Isaiah is
another response to the events of five 87
and it's ultimately a positive
interpretation of positive response.
The punishment that Israel
suffered even if excessive.
Remember Isaiah 40 claims that Israel
has suffered double for her sins, right?
So it's been an excessive punishment,
but that punishment isn't meaningless.
It will lead to redemption.
Israel will be healed by her wounds.
God's Word Will Not Return unfulfilled.
And in addition,
suffering leads to a new role for
Israel among the nations. Second,
Isaiah expresses a new self awareness
that is taking hold in the exile Israel
saw itself as the faithful servant of
Yahweh way a servant whose loyalty to God
in this dark time would serve to broadcast
the knowledge of God throughout the
nations.
So Israel was chosen from the womb
to serve God's universal purpose.
Israel suffered unobserved by others,
but eventually this would make possible
the recognition of God by those others.
When once God,
where once God covenanted with
David to lead his people Israel,
he now covenants with Israel to lead
the nations of the world in God's way.
It's an expansion of God's purpose.
And this is an idea that appears in Isaiah
55 verses three to five incline your
ear and come to me Harkin,
and you shall be revived and I will
make with you an everlasting covenant.
The undoing loyalty promise to David
at the Covenant and loyalty that was
promised to David. I'm now transferring
to you as I made him a leader of peoples,
a prince and commander of peoples.
So you shall summon a nation who you did
not know and a nation that did not know
you shall come running to you for
the sake of the Lord, your God,
the holy one of Israel
who has glorified you.
So God makes an eternal covenant with
Israel like that he wants concluded with
David and the function of the institutions
of the old order are transferred to
the nation as a whole.
What kings and priests and
prophets did for Israel,
Israel will now do for the whole world
as the mediator between the only God and
the nations of the world.
She is a light unto them and all will
ascend to her because from her we'll come
Torah instruction in the
divine will and salvation.
This is the idea of universal mission
that comes out of Second Isaiah.
When we come back on Wednesday,
we're going to take a look at what I
think is probably the single most profound
book in the Hebrew Bible,
the book of Job, and again,
I'll remind you that final
paper information will be
available on the classes
server tonight.
I want you to have it in time to be able
to ask questions of your TF for myself
about the assignment. It's
pretty detailed, so sit and
read through it carefully.
Be there later tonight.